Hey guys, we've got some good news and bad news today
regarding BCP and P.
This is an update as of March 10th, 2022.
I'll give you the bad news first
before you get the good knock.
Skill Level 0
has been removed from the International Graduate stream,
so you must apply
under the Skilled Worker stream now instead.
So you may have gotten an email that
you've been removed from the BCP and P pool.
The good news is
for healthcare workers and early childhood educators,
you will now have targeted draws
and priority processing for PR under BCP and P.
And even more good news is
healthcare assistants and dental assistance
have been added to the entry level
and semi skilled category as eligible occupations.
So there are few more updates
and you should go to the BCP
and P website to make sure that you
have looked at all of them. Take care!